well stirs day it is indeed yes it is
tired cat ran across me at like five
o'clock in the morning I woke up
couldn't go back to sleep yeah and you
didn't get she didn't get much sleep
either because her tooth bothering her
yeah I have like a tooth like way way in
the back and a long time ago it broke
and half of it broke off a half of it
still there and it's really weird
because it hasn't hurt for like a year
year and a half or something like that
and then all of a sudden yesterday it
just started [ __ ] killing me for
whatever reason decides gonna come out I
had that same thing happen I mean I'm
trying to like I don't want to like just
get in there and [ __ ] pry it but it's
like I have been trying to like I still
pinch it a sucker like a Bic pen a
plastic pin underneath mine and just bit
down on it yeah yeah it is hurtin yeah
it's really weird I haven't felt
anything like for a really long time and
then just suddenly yesterday just
started hurting and hurting and then
like by the time I went to bed it was
like [ __ ] killing me and I have like
the gel you know that you put on this to
like kill it but it didn't really work
and I said I was dreaming that we were
at a steak house like eating at a steak
house and I kept like wrenching pieces
of my tooth out and like funny so I was
dreaming about it and then it woke me up
at like it was like quarter to 1:00 and
so and I don't think I fell back to
sleep
after that because then Pookie like kept
calm cuz I think she knew that I didn't
feel good so she kept coming up and like
looking in my face like hey are you okay
yeah and then also Beijing was doing her
weird cargo cult ritual out in the
living room which does that it's right
it's creepy like you know what it is and
you know what she's doing and it's not
nefarious because all she's doing she
comes she comes in my office she gets
like all these I have all these little
stuff to waste and I put him like on the
lower shelf so she can reach them easier
and she has particular one she likes
it's like a little foxhole octopus and
stuff a spider a little spider and a
little bat she likes the bat yeah and
she likes of which he had the little
lock shock and Barrel doll she likes
those it should take some out there
puts him in a circle makes a whole
pattern with him and then just cries to
him it's weird it's weird and it's kind
of an eerie sound like in the middle of
the night she doesn't like every night
so we go up on her she's just standing
over it looking down at a call it out it
just slushy and she does like almost the
same thing it's like when I get up in
the morning she makes like a little
circle like kind of I like in the little
foyer area the like where near with the
laundry room is and then she'll make
like a little line of them going through
the living room like to my office
because she takes out like a whole bunch
like this or seven or eight of them and
she makes like little patterns it's a I
don't know what the patter it's like a
landing pad landing she didn't used to
do that before we got Pookie and we
thought it was some kind of like baby
like a mother instinct thing I'm not
really sure what it is but you trying to
feed Pookie but it's not what it is it's
something she's trying to call down the
the gods to call down to cat spirits
it's weird cuz it's like God more and
more elaborate over the years a whole
pattern and a landing strip circles
circles in life every single morning I
guess we got to take a picture of it
yeah if she gets a really good cuz some
nights I think she doesn't do it like
she'll sleep all that until only be a
couple and there's always at least two
but some morning she gets really like
crazy with it and she like there's a
whole bunch of them and she's like made
like a whole thing
it's a poultrygeist type cuz poltergeist
like behavior that's like some of
poltergeist would do yeah except it's a
cat was the cat I didn't tell you the
other day because Beijing has she's not
um she's never been like as playful as
Pookie is cuz Pookie is very she's like
a little um like a little tomboy she
likes to wrestle and she likes to play
and stuff Beijing has always been kind
of like more aloof like princess like
however she does have a thing where
every now and then she decides that
she's gonna hide behind the wall and
jump on you yeah you come out and she
only does it like once every few months
or something she thinks that shit's
hilarious cuz she runs everything she's
trying to get you to go to get startled
and then she just runs
yeah it's almost like she's like
hahahaha she's run away Kabaddi
yeah and if you and and if even if you
see her you have to pretend that like
she's gay because otherwise she gets
bought I [ __ ] up all time I see her
just off well because sometimes I think
she doesn't realize because she's
looking she's behind the wall and then
she peeks around to see where you are
and she doesn't realize that you can see
her little ears and she's like oh [ __ ]
and then she pulls back in but then [ __ ]
but then she'll jump up on the wall
anyway you know what she did to me that
yesterday or a couple days ago was I
went out in the kitchen and I was like
[ __ ] you know making coffee or
whatever the hell I was doing and she
tried to jump out at me but she like I
guess she miscalculated where I was
going to be because she jumped out from
behind the wall like two walls behind me
goodness she was like wow and then she
was like oh yeah over there never mind
and then she like tried to play it off I
was just going to the litter box I
wasn't doing anything funny we're still
we're still working on the cookbook
coming up with new concepts I'm gonna
put a Chinese section in there cuz I
know you guys like Chinese food and I
got some Chinese stuff that I make it's
very easy you know like sweet and sour
chicken and pork and then like General
Tso's chicken I'm gonna show you how
yeah you make that all the time and I
make variations of that using different
components you'll see
and then the condiments Chinese
condiments you like the mustard and the
duck sauce
I got much better versions of that what
else although I have to say that not a
lot of the Asian food that we make and
even on like some other things like
sometimes when you just make pork chops
and stuff I don't know what [ __ ]
brand it is I think didn't somebody we
got it at Sam's or Aldi I can't remember
but it comes like in this really big
bottle and it's like pineapple habanero
it's like yeah like we got that of Sam's
yeah and it's like I don't know if you
can get it all the time but it's like
I'm not that [ __ ] not there anymore
everything it's kind of like it's kind
of that's kind of like something you
could put egg rolls in yeah yeah
pineapple heaven
sauce it's kind of like it's kind of
like sweet chilli sauce kind of like
Thai sweet chili sauce yeah it's really
really like that um I put it on a whole
bunch of things we're gonna talk about
crab rangoon yeah we'll talk about egg
rolls how to make those do you want to
do sushi you haven't made sushi in a
long time yeah soo she's a [ __ ] you
gotta have right Constitution mats for
it and everything you need you need the
right rice it's just the distinct kind
of rice that's only for people that's
really interested [ __ ] we're you know I
mean it's we we made it a few times like
just with um you know with the imitation
crab like avocado and stuff like that
it's a [ __ ] it's hard to do though it's
like hard to roll it up and like get it
sold it's easy to miss calculate when
you're making like a sushi roll and put
too much in it and then you roll it and
it's like that big around this so it's
it's it's it's something that takes a
few months of [ __ ] trial and error to
get right Chinese food is known in the
United States and in Europe is American
it's not Chinese yes Chinese American
well it's just like the Italian food
that we have fair it's not like exactly
what they'd eat in Italy but it's just
like immigrants yeah and it's you can
trace it back to San Francisco back in
the late 1800 yeah that had the largest
Chinese population outside of China yep
been there forever
and the Chinese just we're grifton on us
and they can they realize that you could
just take American components and mess
around with them and sell it to the
white man and go yeah that's that's our
Chinese food they don't eat that [ __ ]
when almost called chop suey Chop Suey
means table scraps as far as that is not
a Chinese dish that's something they
were just given to us I think it means
table scraps yeah they were bought
that's pretty funny to think yeah
they're trollers rolling that's the only
thing and in like some of the most
famous stuff like General Tso's chicken
that's not Chinese either it's actually
from like Singapore that's where that it
was a Chinese chef yeah it didn't we for
a Japanese chef Chinese food in a
Singaporean restaurant didn't we see a
documentary about the history of that
yeah it's on this time
it is not Chinese not in anyways its if
but it is it is from you know the East
it was and it's also not old it's from
the 60s a lot of [ __ ] people think is
old in traditional food is not old like
Cajun food I was just gonna I was gonna
say they're like same thing jambalaya
especially kind of spice all Prudhomme
it's all over don't ya it's not old yeah
and it's it's not it's you know it's not
traditional percent delicious delicious
you're talking about late 60s yeah late
sixties or was he
those were his recipes from from you
know New Orleans area area you know in
round Louisiana he bullshitted his way
into said yeah this is a traditional
Cajun food no it's not it's it was
inspired yeah by Cajun food but no not
not not in any you know no no way but
that's kind of one of the coolest things
that I was and that's why I'm always
fascinated with like food history and
stuff like that I don't think you can
get too wrapped up in you know if
something's like traditional cuisine or
something like that because I mean
especially now when you know everybody
likes to try everybody else's different
cuisines and stuff and people are like
mixing it together if it's good who
[ __ ] cares yeah there's nothing none
of this food is old you go back you go
back and look at a recipe books from the
40s and you wouldn't [ __ ] eat that you
just would need it it's [ __ ] terrible
yeah I would I wouldn't eat most of this
stuff there's a whole channel about
[ __ ] people executing old red old
recipes from the sixties in the 40s it's
not edible the palates of most of it the
palates of those days and the supplies
the things that they have to had access
to is crap most of it can [ __ ]
[ __ ] ate aspic
yeah love that [ __ ] well no that is this
damn meat gelatin meat jelly yeah and
it's clear you can make different colors
and [ __ ] the the only thing I would say
is probably like traditional Cajun that
I come
would be like boudin and you don't want
[ __ ] Buddha it's a damn ball fried
balls [ __ ] nasty it's all internal
organs and [ __ ] and not internal organs
from anything you'd ever eat anyway
might be internal organs from a [ __ ]
possum mixed with [ __ ] like fish
mixed with [ __ ] like a beef heart and
it's just you know they had laying or
just whatever they [ __ ] had and it
was something that nobody else it eat
and that was the only time I ever got
sick in the south because I can eat
boudin all right and but you wouldn't
even want to eat boudin I stopped off at
a gas station one time that some fresh
boudin came out and they put it up in
the little window you know that man yeah
and and there was only a dollar I said
let me give amber a what what did you
ask for your dollar back at the end I
was driving driving so was a [ __ ]
just pass Slidell and I was going I was
on my way to New Orleans you know goth
night coming up yeah and [ __ ] I was
eating some [ __ ] boudin and I
finished about half of it and all of a
sudden I started feeling [ __ ] strange
man straining nothing through that
[ __ ] half a ball out cuz in the South
you just throw that [ __ ] out yeah just
dish it out the way I don't throw a pig
toilet paper I just the [ __ ] thing on
the freeway but if it's like she just
integrated Upton and all of a sudden I
started feeling light-headed I [ __ ]
pulled over and just threw up oh no yeah
that [ __ ] was rotten yeah whatever that
was what something was in there that had
turned and they [ __ ] gave it to me as
sure as hell I'm gonna go back there and
get that [ __ ] for a dollar and the South
eight is just denied it yeah must be you
you you much of a [ __ ] - yeah yeah
that's what they would have said yeah
that's putting [ __ ] bascomb on - but
it was it was something like I could
taste there was some kind of internal
organ in there but it's like liver there
it's a very like still used to liver or
something that was in there it was bad
whatever it was or not it didn't taste
bad but it was it was robbed yeah man
that's [ __ ] I remember that and I was
dizzy for about a half
after throw it up god it cleared though
yeah it cleared yeah that was our lead
oh yeah I got rid of it earlier the
ejector seat um I do feel like well
that's not it's not really a southern
thing but they do eat a lot of like
testicles right like Mountain Oysters
yeah I never had it I never ate I
thought I think I saw my grandfather
eating it I'm like that's that that's
not in the south no that's what I mean
that's that's that's like I thought that
was Midwestern might be Appalachia yeah
they probably do that but not not down
south Davis southern man's not gonna put
another man [ __ ] that [ __ ] came off
another species they're gonna give
they're gonna get Southern Baptist their
interpretation of that my words like
homosexual bestiality yeah but you're
getting tea-bagged by another piece yeah
there's gonna be a Southern Baptist
interpretation of you like say you want
to put another man's balls in your mouth
and then man's a sheep that's how
they're gonna look at that I mean it
goes down digest your stomach and then
it becomes part of your [ __ ] flesh so
you're made out of balls they're gonna
try to look at it that way what would
Jesus think of it also you might get
pregnant
am I not get beyond the pearly gates
part made out of sheet testicle yeah I
never heard of it it might be a so it
might be as a Mississippi sin maybe it
might be I heard it with my grandfather
my right and my grandfather's from
Tennessee now I don't know like how cuz
I know they call them mountain oysters
or Rocky Mountain Oysters well they they
mention them but they're not from
Mississippi yeah that's they're from
somewhere else and they're gone and and
like I've seen them I've just yeah yeah
my gonna eat that [ __ ] no and every time
they were ever mentioned they were
making fun of
yeah like you eat them you know like I
bet you eat that you know people you
know yeah but like what I'm saying is
you're not listening what I'm saying at
least in Jones County Mississippi all
right
it was kind of made that they made fun
of Rocky Mountain Oysters yeah okay so
you weren't so that so just you can
directly infer by that that you're not
supposed to eat them they're making fun
enough yeah anything that's anything
that's ridiculing whose idea with that
this is one thing that has always
fascinated me like some food why like
some [ __ ] that grows and stuff like that
it's like it seems like obvious like it
smells good you know or something like
that but you're getting you're getting
your big butt who was the first person
to eat yeah light has to go see I'm
right you're you're you're getting me to
explain it to you I'd know exactly what
it is it was a dare no I know exactly
what it is but it might spoil this
upcoming show okay if they don't say
yeah it was related to bodybuilding I
would think okay all right I'll go okay
I'll tell you a little bit more sorry
in ancient times okay we're going back
to like a Roman era flashback
Oh every bit of a [ __ ] animal was
eaten yeah every bit of it which you can
understand that it's less wasteful [ __ ]
it it seems to be from what we know at
that time [ __ ] like bull dick and bull
nuts was kind of saved and cherished by
athletes because or dudes that wanted
[ __ ] a lot of prowess okay yeah cuz
it would be it was like gaining more
masculinity yeah okay masculine energy
so what you're talking about is you're
talking about the performance-enhancing
drug of the day yeah you know Tom they
say footballs
that make me as strong as an ox make you
strong as a bull make you big as a bull
or make a dick big as a bulls dick
whatever now because that [ __ ] was going
on you know
it was theorized in the in the 1900s
okay well no it was theorized in the mid
to late 1900s okay that some of the
[ __ ] men that had these fantastic
physiques in ancient times you know I
mean like the statues these guys maybe
they gained that by eating bull nuts
because that's where testosterone is and
that might be kind of like TRT or taking
steroids yeah it's not like crazy not a
crazy concept all right but it turns out
that it that it was wrong yeah you can't
get enough testosterone inside a nut
okay has a very short half-life and even
if you take even if you were able to get
testosterone directly directly out of a
[ __ ] testicle and inject it into your
body within a few minutes it would be
converted into something else like the
estrogen anyway yeah all right so it
wouldn't be in there long enough for you
to build any muscle on it or to have any
response
it wasn't until anabolic steroids that
you could have an effect like that yeah
now some people as this is a teaser okay
for the show
some people thought that some of the
strongmen of the late 1800s okay may
have gotten their hands on some kind of
testosterone or something kind of like
it anabolic steroids testosterone was
kind of like discovered and isolated I
think in the 20s that sometimes and they
didn't know about it all right in the
30s and the 40s but it really wasn't
they weren't able to synthesize this
[ __ ] into anything that you can eject
and anything that would work until
really the 50s yeah okay and even in the
50s it would have been very very
expensive kind of rare so there's no way
the the strongmen of the of the late
1800s
and any kind of performance-enhancing
drugs what you saw what was that's what
was possible just pure natty pure
natural just lifting weights and eating
protein yeah well you remember and I
think I brought it up on the show before
but do you remember there was that one
quack doctor that was going around
saying that he was giving men a sexual
prowess by putting goat testicles in her
screwed yeah that [ __ ] didn't work it
was rejected uh no and it also didn't
produced any test us also chilled some
of you killed so it's total quackery
yeah it was a good book though if you
look at about Eugen Sandow and Pat and
Pandora just look at photos of them
that's natural they had no
performance-enhancing drugs and so
that's just that that's what's possible
without any steroids and just working
out and at least having above-average
genes yeah he probably had an above
average gene some say that you know
maybe maybe maybe Sandow just had
average genes because the only reason
why he ended up like that's cuz he was
looking at Greek statues I'm thinking I
think I can do that
coming up with this crazy idea of
lifting weights
nobody had nobody in that era had
thought of that yeah he's kind of like
the father right but he did prove that
the ancient Greeks and the Romans knew
about bodybuilding and lifting weights
that those statues were accurate they
were based on real people and real
proportions that were possible because
for thousands of years people thought
that that was [ __ ] there's just like
an idealized I thought was an idealized
cartoon and people didn't look like that
they're just they're you know they're
making that up that people can't look
like that yes they can the Romans and
the Greeks had what you would call
sports medicine they knew about it yeah
well that was like a big part of their
culture yeah going back to like you know
wrestling and the Olympics
Pech ratios what they call you know
[ __ ] Greek sports and they were big
into the
and that was their version of technology
biotechnology is what they're talking
about yeah yeah you know there's there's
some [ __ ] going on right now you know in
the health fitness world about all this
vegan power you had Arnold
Schwarzenegger coming out with this damn
all vegan diet and and this video
there's promoting it I think it's called
the game changers showing all these
people building all this muscle on a
totally vegetarian vegan diet and I'm
gonna tell you guys something I don't
wanna hurt anybody feelings this total
[ __ ] [ __ ] its total [ __ ] you
can't do it Arnold didn't build a muscle
that way and if you know who Arnold
Schwarzenegger is what kind of guy is
Arnold's the biggest bullshitters out
there that do he had a long long history
of bullshitting he would say the
craziest if this is true this is people
that knew him they didn't say man how'd
you get so big you know he'd tell him
some crazy [ __ ] like taking a couple
drops of dish water and put it inside a
[ __ ] beer and drink it you see he got
people putting dishwater inside of beer
to get big that's what kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] Arnold with taylean
the hour was [ __ ] you he thought
that [ __ ] was hilarious well it's
hilarious that you that you would fall
for that yeah I think it was beer
I can't narrow exactly what it was so
easy it was crazy [ __ ] why does it
everybody look like Arnold Storm
steroids anabolic steroids that's how
you get that bit he's pretty much of the
answer to that question anabolic
steroids eat a lot of [ __ ] protein
and they don't even have to work out
that much I mean he did because he was
[ __ ] on stage but you could take the
the right kind of anabolic steroids and
workout just some and get [ __ ] big in
a short period of time yes if you work
out a lot you'll get even bigger
you'll get bigger than a human pony
humanly possible I mean they're going 20
pounds over whatever your genetic limit
is that's what that's what that's what
steroids unlocks some guys take it they
never even really hit their genetic
limit they just gained like 20 30 pounds
because they were little weaklings
didn't really hit their genetic limit
and then they stopped but some of these
guys are
after genetic limit then they take
[ __ ] anabolic steroids on top of that
and get [ __ ] huge 20 pounds on 20
pounds of pure muscle on top of what is
possible you know that's just not
something in nature and the de santé box
is the only way yeah and that's the
truth
that is all this game change of [ __ ]
when you see these guys there are fake
Nattie's people that are say they're
100% natural [ __ ] fake okay
he's not natural there's a bunch of
different ways that you can tell alright
so not only have fake Naturals you got
fake vegans guys saying he's saying he's
natural saying he's vegan by my own
[ __ ] book the [ __ ] he might be
vegetarian but he's eating [ __ ]
protein whey powder you know protein
powder a bunch of creatine and then
steroids they do that too and then oh
I'm all natural all vegan [ __ ] well
it's the same thing is you remember back
in the day when they had those [ __ ]
infomercials for you know whatever like
the shake weight or less step aerobics
and it's like they'd have all these
people on here and it's like they got
fit doing that no they no they didn't
know that no that is a fitness model
that they hired to shake weight they
hold the shake weight you think we
didn't have anything to do with how they
look nothing nothing business that's how
they just [ __ ] tell it to you the
fitness products are a scam largely
you're a [ __ ] scam they are you get
fit by lifting weights and eating and
lifting weights and running and eating
there's none of these little [ __ ]
shake weights and doodads and [ __ ] they
didn't get that way it's sequin there
dude and then and then they do [ __ ] like
taking Psalms or taking [ __ ] steroids
or taking [ __ ] TRT testosterone
replacement you got women taking
testosterone and if it's taken right
they look good but you know look up
Bakar know what's the name back our
[ __ ] ie just gouge it with black eyes
and [ __ ] all muscle you know looks
good big old booty and she wears [ __ ]
bondage clothes and [ __ ] nike not back
hard not knock Eva or something I think
that's what her name was but
she got it and soon she speaks sounds
like a man no [ __ ] testosterone man
[ __ ] hell the drug turn try to blow
it into a mass turn into a female hi I
don't want that takes it closed off quit
[ __ ] comes out like three inches long
comin at you pass slapped my jacket yeah
trying to [ __ ] mount unit but yeah get
the [ __ ] yeah
anyway um but yeah did you know it's
just there's a lot of [ __ ] out there
about what's natural what you know what
isn't natural you know you can you can
work out lift weights for five years and
if you're [ __ ] real young and you had
good genes in five years you'll be able
to [ __ ] have a [ __ ] fantastic
transformation but you'll never be able
to [ __ ] be to do this on steroids
never dude that [ __ ] can start from
just an average body and in 18 months of
[ __ ] anabolics the right way he can
make [ __ ] ten years of gains no
better than ten it looks like what you
would gain in ten years plus a little
bit more on all kinds of [ __ ] weird
angles and insertions and [ __ ]
definitions is something that can there
never be done naturally there's just not
enough fat you know they're down [ __ ]
2% body fat that's just not possible
yeah not without anabolics so just hate
the [ __ ] crash everybody's dreams
well I don't think everybody was
dreaming they have some you know it was
look at that [ __ ] go I think I could do
that now you'll never be able to [ __ ]
get you'll never be able to compete with
dudes that are on anabolics no well and
I really do feel like I was watching a
documentary earlier for a good you know
for the show we're gonna do but um they
were talking about how you know mr.
Olympia and all that was kind of like
you know competitions now it's just all
about how freakishly huge yeah can you
get it's not really about the aesthetics
of it anymore and we have been natural
like how can you get like your best
natural self everybody just wants to
look like a big roided-out monster yeah
well actually that's kind of going away
though now yeah well I feel like they
were talking about like they were like
the last kind of like big thing like um
you know the aesthetic type of thing was
like in the 90s was kind of like the
heyday but then like after that it
started going in the direction of
everybody wanted to look like a
roided-out monster yeah that that ended
with Ronnie Coleman Ronnie Coleman yeah
that's one of the guys that was yeah he
proved how big you can get you can get a
[ __ ] car a normal basically basically
and he's in a bus and he's [ __ ] up now
his [ __ ] spines all [ __ ] up his
skeletons all [ __ ] up and you know it
he just cost him but he was he went all
in he wanted to see how big a
[ __ ] can get Ronnie Coleman yeah
I respect his game you know he got
[ __ ] huge cost him his spine no he's
just like yeah who's in pain you know
yeah this documentary I was five it was
five years old yeah so it's going to go
back it's going back to classic physique
yeah which is big arms big chest normal
size legs vacuum pose which means you
can pull your gut in you know the
meaning good definition and something
that Arnie was a [ __ ] perfect Arnold
Schwarzenegger when he's at his greatest
was [ __ ] the greatest classic
physique that and if you put him next to
Ronnie Coleman he looked little next to
Ronnie Coleman you know people think of
how big Arnold was he wasn't that big
really
yeah that's motion your mom later yeah
yeah the standards change you'd look at
him now he'd just be like an average guy
at the gym yeah but you know in his not
really but to that to the untrained eye
he'd be the average guy average big guy
at the gym but it's gonna be interesting
showed as we I think you guys like it
I'll dispel some myths what I yeah you
know it's kind of something that I
didn't really know a great deal about
but I've been like research and stuff
like that yeah I'm kind of interested in
like in the you know the old history
like
gin-san down all of that yeah another
thing is is that you got girls growing
up today on Instagram they're looking at
these other girls on Instagram with
these [ __ ] very voluptuous looking
figures with nice [ __ ] booties and
there's a [ __ ] legs and [ __ ] some of
that [ __ ] looks like crap because that's
implants but but implants just don't
look right especially if they're too big
women doesn't have any legs but some of
the better ones that that are very
famous they're making hundreds of
thousands or millions of dollars a year
I don't know [ __ ] promoting [ __ ] on
snapchat maybe selling nude selfies
that's like what every bodybuilder used
to do anyway turn sell nude selfies and
[ __ ] um I hate to break it to you guys
but almost all those girls what I've
seen from what I'm seeing or at least on
Psalms that's how they get those legs
like that that's how that's how you can
have voluptuous chests big booty big
muscles and then have a skinny waist
yeah
you know I mean because that very rarely
happens in nature that's that [ __ ] like
m'kay no it's [ __ ] like [ __ ] Austrian
and car terrine and rad 140 that's what
they're using to do that yeah and
they're come they're doing cycles of
that it's sarbs are kind of like a like
a like a avatar or like kind of like a
hologram of a steroid it's not a steroid
but it makes your body kind of think
that you had one but it'll never be as
good as real steroids real steroids will
[ __ ] get you much bigger much faster
but it's not harder on your system
[ __ ] Psalms are a lot more gentle
most of them there's a bunch of them but
in general the SARM is now I'm not
trying to promote any of the use of this
kind of [ __ ] but it's out there you guys
can find it it's legal yeah you know
I've taken some so I'm not I'm not a
hundred percent natural I you can call
me it's kind of like slightly modified
but only in the past couple months yeah
and ass arm will never make you
superhuman you'll never be able to
get beyond your own your own normal
limit anyway usually what it does what
they do is is they do things like speed
up healing but you still gotta lift yeah
you know when you hit 50 years your
healing slows down a lot so you're gonna
need you're gonna need help to [ __ ]
heal up if you want to workout to three
times a week but so you know but that's
how it is none of that's just natural
lifting weights is not natural training
for things is not natural you know well
that's what I mean none of that shit's
now if you only did shift it was natural
we'd all still be sitting around living
in caves and lowering animal skins and
we wouldn't shave anything yeah even a
natural bodybuilder you got a question
well that's not really natural what he's
doing and then what they're eating is
not something that you would find in
nature yeah like you just can't you just
don't have access to that I'm that much
protein in a day or in the wild you
can't hunt down that many rabbits you
can't kill that many birds you can't eat
that much fish you just can't get that
much creatine and in nature you know
yeah there's not protein bar trees no
nothing is natural yeah even what women
do all the [ __ ] beauty stuff that
they do it's not natural that's what I
mean I don't want to go around looking
natural for that [ __ ] horrifying so
there's like this big [ __ ] thing it's
been going on in Fitness for a long time
who is that whose natural and whose
enhanced they're all enhanced it's it's
a blurry line yeah they're all there's
really no hard and fast I don't ask that
anymore I just want to know who's on
gear and who is it
who's on steroids and who isn't because
really the [ __ ] that makes the big
difference is the photo steroids yeah
yeah this you can take all this little
creatine you know it's protein powders
and diesel sarbs that ain't [ __ ]
compared to [ __ ] D ball or an oval or
anavar you get [ __ ] huge big yeah
like I said some of the guys I was on
[ __ ] if I was on [ __ ] real
steroids and I've been
been working out with two years now yeah
something like that yeah and with that
two years if I had been doing cycles of
[ __ ] steroids I'd be [ __ ] 30
pounds heavier use your arms be so big
you and be like yeah I look ridiculous
really a lot of that [ __ ] to me looks
ridiculous too much yeah it doesn't
really look like yeah I do not want to
be above normal human level yeah
no no man I just want to be nearer what
my genetic potential was yeah cuz like I
said after after a point it just starts
look as freaky she's too much and yeah I
just never really wanted to work out to
become superhuman and and a bad thing
about it is is that once you start going
above your genetic potential you have to
remain on those steroids to keep that
muscle yeah when you [ __ ] come off of
it over time it goes right down to what
your potential was again well your
genetic but does so why were you doing
this the only way that's right you
there's only two reasons why you do that
you do it because you're competing in
some kind of show which is a glorified
beauty contest which that's fine
all right or you got manorexia yeah
where you're looking in the mirror and
for some reason you don't think you're
big enough and I don't really understand
that because if you look at what a
person's maximum genetic potential is
that's pretty [ __ ] big yeah for me
you know I mean to me it looks like
usually somebody's somebody's genetic
max kinda looks real close to what
classic physique was with Arnold not
quite that big but similar proportions
ya know good enough yeah good enough so
I you know I don't understand it some
guys just going it's kind of the same
thing as like people that get plastic
surgery it's like up to a point
yeah you look better but then there
comes a point rook it just starts
looking you start looking less and less
like a person yeah they're looking more
and more like freakish the mass monsters
and the mass monsters and the guys that
want to go 20 pounds over their genetic
potential are basically not kinda like
the men's version so those porn starts
with the big basketball boobs the big
type that can't even like [ __ ] it
they came moving
[ __ ] big fake lips and the [ __ ]
huge book which there's a certain amount
of novelty to it you know I mean [ __ ]
you know I think it looks kind of cool
you might get tired of it after a while
but in photographs it looks kind of
[ __ ] like a like a fetish model I can
understand it but you know I mean this
it is an extreme look well I was writing
about in my book there's one case she
was um a porn star named Lola Ferrari
I remember her yeah and she was in the
you know Guinness Book of World Records
for like world's biggest breasts because
she had like 10 or 20 different
surgeries like to give you bigger and
bigger bigger and she got to a point
where yeah she had really bad back
problems she couldn't sleep she had to
sleep on her side I think she couldn't
sleep on her back or on her stomach yeah
was she a little skinny too
yeah she ended up dying and they are not
sure if it was suicide or if her husband
might have killed her
yeah which is why it's in my book
because it's not they're not sure it's a
murder but there's yeah her family tends
to think it was a murder and there is
some evidence to suggest there's a
German one just like that nowadays
same kind of builder than her stage name
is uh Penelope black diamond something
great name yeah she actually looks like
somebody would know like a goth chick
they're gonna be in a big long black
here with bangs and skinny
yeah she looks like Laura you know mark
and Laura look yeah it looks like she
looks like Laura Connor but I mean each
boob has gotta be about the size of a
beach ball I couldn't imagine going
around it's not like you could take them
off at that no I know you know big long
fingernails and big long toenails on her
see that I was wondered about to you
because I you know every now and then
like if I'm you know if we're going some
special occasion or something like that
exist fake nails on and [ __ ] yeah you
can't get the car I can't get the car
the first time I try to go to the
bathroom and pull my pants back up they
start snap and I'm like how the [ __ ] do
people do this
yeah I don't understand they don't stay
on I don't know us you can't so I just
feel like all the time I'm like I can't
move I can't touch anything I can't pick
anything up it's like I hate it yeah but
yeah so
yeah but I kind of psychologically I
kind of put roided-out mass monsters and
[ __ ] bimbos bimbo pornstar type like
Penelope black time I think it's
psychologically is similar it's a
similar yes where they're going for
extremes yeah well and you know or
people like you know that that person
that that had like they wanted to look
like snake or whatever yeah like
although some of the people like that's
their livelihood so in a way I can
understand it's like it's still a dream
behavior but well porn stars and
bodybuilders that's their livelihood to
it is there but I think there's also
kind of a psychological Drive you have
to want that you have to without that
really bad because like I said when
you're not competing you still look like
they look like that and but they're
happy looking like that that's what they
want
yeah you see I think they have the right
I don't understand why it's illegal I
don't really don't because I think a
person has a right to choose you know I
mean to how they want to look and if
they want to take care of bollocks
steroids yeah it might kill him earlier
but so does smoking so there's a bunch
of other [ __ ] yeah so does booze
yes it's like it's if it's the person's
own body and that's and as long as they
don't have any like underlying issues
they're not hurting anybody they're not
you know it's like maybe not what I
would do and it's like but if you want
to do that then you hear them out you
hear them they're going like god these
guys are going like yeah this this might
kill me early but I'm trading quality of
life partying for life for quality of
life says I'm gonna have a real good
quality life until I die this is what I
want to do I enjoy looking like this I
feel good yeah really argue with that
who these mothers to tell him he can't
take that yeah and that he can't look
like that or do that you know sorry he
knows he's he knows what he's getting
into
all she's doing is [ __ ] with his
hormones basically yeah and women have
been [ __ ] with her hormones so they
don't get pregnant for [ __ ] years now
what yeah why can't a man [ __ ] with his
hormones yeah to get bigger or to feel
better you know [ __ ] after 50 so I
don't really understand it it doesn't
make any sense to me well a lot of a lot
of stuff that's oh and it's an American
thing
here in the United States for some
reason I guess it was the meteor
whatever stare
it's got real villified there's kind of
like a social faux pas that these guys
are taking them but in Europe it's like
normal in Germany it's like oh yeah it
takes steroids they just they just do it
you know they don't have a problem with
it and I think they're I think they're
legal in England they might be just it
I'd have to check right you want to take
them take them I do feel like well even
in drugs in particular I feel like
Europeans are a lot more kind of life
yeah Americans are it's there it's
really weird there's this just this
really like strange like puritanical
kind of streak in the culture still it's
not as bad as it used to be like I think
like it was bad in the eighties like
that but there's still this kind of
thing where it's like oh it's drugs it's
bad yes yeah I mean drugs are [ __ ]
it's a mixed bag it's like anything else
yeah like yeah you don't want to give
drugs to a kid especially if those drugs
might affect him later on right or it's
a cancer-causing agent that might kill
you in 40 years you might die at 50 you
know what I mean but who cares you give
that same drug to a guy who's 50 he's
gonna die tell him what it is yeah if
he's 50 he might only have 30 years of
life left anyway 40 years of you know I
mean so that means he's gonna live a
normal I spend yeah so he should you
know because some of this stuff if you
look at it if it's used properly based
on dudes that I've seen actually do it
it looks like it's life extension yeah
we don't have a lot of good examples yet
but you look at Sylvester Stallone he
was on and off [ __ ] his whole life he
looked good for a [ __ ] it's almost 75
year old man you know true he probably
looked a lot better had he not taking
anything until he was 50 yeah
you know because it does do damage to
your [ __ ] liver and probably who
knows what it does to your DNA I don't
know is it it puts your system into
overdrive to grow plus he's taking a
bunch of HGH but now we're going down
with these people pride I wanna hear
this [ __ ] well like I said we're gonna
do a show about that kind of thing is
like yeah oh the guys that pioneered
this [ __ ] and why certain things went
down the way it did that's what we're
gonna talk about yeah Aaron what's
possible what's not
possible yeah you know I'm done all
right
turn that [ __ ] off yeah we wouldn't I
guess it was almost 45 minutes was it
it's like a whole [ __ ] bonus show
look guys like the show please like
share and subscribe become a patron
how many patrons we have now do you know
20:57 we could always use it we're at
the point now where we could always use
new patrons even if it's only a couple
dollars we still got to do the video for
the YouTube membership and we got to get
shirts out soon but things are just
starting to kind of get back to normal
around here we can have we gotta go up
to [ __ ] Michaels and we gotta go to
the printers to get new design yeah but
like I said and we start working on the
cookbook and we need to do like yeah I
got a lot of work well gets everything's
just I'm just trying to take things a
little bit at a time you know I don't
get stressed out all right so uh you
guys have a great rest of your Thursday
we'll be talking to you again tomorrow